real quick in one of the absolutely
wildest unhinged rants of the Mike
pillow era
he went on TV after a brief Hiatus his
own show I think it's important to say
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines yeah not that but
he now is claiming to have people and
cameras watching polling places in every
County as well as so-called cyber guys
that can look inside voting machines in
real time
if he's lying then he's very ill
if he's telling the truth these are
probably crimes listen to this this
election and I'm telling everyone out
there we are watching from every angle
where there's people in every state
every County every Precinct Brandon
remember they may think you can't look
and see what's going inside that black
box but we can now in real time through
something called The Edison report
everybody right we have cyber guys
watching this we I looked at a thing
today it was on my my Twitter back from
November of 2020 and they showed CNN 20
000 votes dropping right off at Donald
Trump's total in real time you guys
votes don't go in reverse these are
computer manipulation algorithms so what
I'm telling you is this election it's
all eyes we have all the camera angles
now why now everyone would say well Mike
why are you telling the bad guys right
now
well I'm telling them Brad they are the
bad guys because the way I look at it
we're gonna it's gonna be a win-win
because the ones where we can override
the algorithms are going to be there
they're going to win
and then also the ones they don't all of
it we got it all under camera well maybe
this time around the judges and the the
left with the left media and maybe even
the right Media Fox News and Newsmax
will actually report if there's machines
that are involved in this election to
steal another election yeah listen I
don't know whether he thinks he's
telling the truth or whether he's
delusional or whether it is the truth
and he's admitting to crimes I don't
know about any of it but we need to get
Beyond this type of thinking for every
pillow man
there are
ten thousand fifty thousand two hundred
and fifty thousand people who literally
believe this stuff is it a million I
don't know it is a sickness it is a
sickness and for everybody who's been
asking me hey you know David Mike pillow
when you interviewed him a couple weeks
ago he said he was going to send you
some free pillows so for you to try them
did he ever do it no he did not
so that also but by the way I'm very
happy with the pillows I have but I
would have been curious to try the mic
pillows he also did not do that